welcome to the strength Fest the dreaded
ice chocolate
are you ready
the Horsemen's ax
used by mounted Knights and armies the
Horseman's ax became the weapon of
choice after body armor made swords less
effective
the heavier ax with its concave blade
allowed Horsemen to strike more
effective blows using a sweeping
overhead stroke that penetrated armor
early depictions of medieval warfare
shows the X cleaving an opponent's
helmet delivering a fatal strike
in the film Sleepy Hollow the Headless
Horseman wields a Horseman's ax
placements this is the kill test the
Horseman's ax it's actually two weapons
in one it's got an edge that can
lacerate and chop and a spike that can
penetrate and Crush bones to see what
kind of lethal damage your ax will do I
will take your Horseman's ax and deliver
lethal blows on this ballistics dummy
Mike you're up first you ready yes I am
as you can see I'm recovering from an
injury so one of my students will have
the satisfaction of testing your weapon
thank you
well Mike let's talk about your weapon
your Edge over here is sharp it
lacerated deep into the bowels right
here your Spike definitely caved in all
the way into the chest and straight into
the heart the only issue we have is that
your handle is a little bit on the
rounded side so there is a tendency to
slightly roll but overall your weapon
will kill thank you Alex you're up next
you ready yes let's do this all right
I'm pretty proud of what I created it's
just a little heavy and that's a bit of
a concern going in
foreign
Alex your weapon here is a little bit on
the heavy side
but you know what it is well balanced
the edge of your blade here cut deep
into chest cavity and it broke the bones
your Spike here right into the heart and
of course on a swing it pretty much just
disemboweled the dummy right there your
weapon
will kill yes thank you next up is a
strength test Jake now we know ice can
be very brutal on an edge so I'm going
to take your Horsemen's axes and
repeatedly strike into these large
blocks Vice to see how well they hold up
Mike you're up first you ready yes I am
[Music]
foreign
like unfortunately we had a serious
failure on your ax
with this weld point in the junction of
the belt hook
Alex you still have to pass this test
are you ready yes I'm ready
there's only one thing standing between
me and a ten thousand dollar check and
it's really big and it's made of ice
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
Alex your Horseman's ax did quite a job
on that ice
everything's still tight your edges
still razor sharp thank you
so all in all very nicely done
blade Smith's our weapons tests here are
designed to be exceptionally brutal in
order to set your weapons apart from one
another Mike your blade did not survive
our strength test for that reason I have
to ask you to please leave the forge
okay
I am disappointed but when I go home I'm
going to have a smile on my face
forged and fire has risen me from the
dead somehow
I will take this forward with me for the
rest of my life
Alex congratulations you are the forest
and fire champion and will be receiving
a check for ten thousand dollars good
job
[Applause]
foreign
it's surreal it's really surreal well
come on over here and Shake our hands oh
wow I can't really fathom like I've won
like I I want definitely tops everything
else I've ever done being the fortune
fire Champion just shows I've applied
what I've always tried to teach others
never stop learning
[Music]
the soda gourami holy geez
one of the most intimidating and
versatile Japanese pole weapons the Soto
gourame was part of the key Arsenal for
Samurai police during the 17th century
featuring lethal spikes and hooks police
were able to capture violent offenders
from The Distance by using the weapon to
latch onto the suspects stopping them in
their tracks although primarily used in
defense the sharp spikes along with the
spiked Bud cap made it a menacing and
brutal weapon when in combat today the
Soto garame's devastating use can be
seen in the HBO television series
Westworld alright bladesmiths welcome to
the kill test
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your Saudi garami will do I will take
your weapons and stab and try to snag
this ballistics dummy Rita you're up
first you ready for this hi all right
let's do this
foreign
[Music]
the times you have here penetrates the
hook you have here will rip this person
apart and more importantly your weapon
little keel
all right Justin your attorney you ready
to have fun yes sir
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
rather than a grabbing this is a
grabbing weapon but that hook does grab
on to that overall sir your weapon
killed
alright bladesmiths it's time for the
strength test the dreaded ice block chop
remember this is not about what these
weapons do to the ice blocks but with
those ice blocks due to your weapons and
Rita you're up first you get points for
theme I mean
you ready
it doesn't matter right oh it doesn't
matter
foreign
[Music]
got a little bit more of a bend in this
one tine here
but everything else is pretty much the
way it was going in definitely held up
did its job good job thank you
all right Justin your turn you ready yes
I am
foreign
so you survived the strength test this
is a very strong uh well-built head for
this but it's built more like a spear
than it is for catching I mean I'm not
sure how effective it would be at
snagging the opponent but uh it's a
Devastator it certainly did the job good
job
all right blade Smiths welcome to the
sharpness test the Sandman Pierce and
capture
it's just a sharpness I will take your
weapon Pierce and try to control this
Sandman relay up first you ready for
this
[Music]
all right we left the points you have on
your times here definitely penetrate
when you thrust into that but it doesn't
Slice on the way out or capture as well
as it should
your hook over here did its job overall
it will cut in control
all right Justin your turn so you ready
yes I am
that's not good
well Justin we have a problem yes sir
this wasn't pinned was it no the impact
from all these tests loosened it up and
of course it came off
Justin you brought in a beautifully
crafted weapon however you've suffered a
catastrophic failure in our final test
and unfortunately you cannot be our
Forge and fire Champion congratulations
Rita thank you awesome
coming on Forest and fire I'll put my
all into it and I feel like I made a
good weapon but uh just came up short on
a little bit of the fit and finish and
other than that I'm happy with it
[Music]
Rita congratulations you are the fortune
fire champion and that is the title that
comes with a check for ten thousand
dollars congratulations how do you feel
right now
look forward to shake our hands good job
it's been a very positive and uplifting
experience to be able to do something
amazing like this I hope this will help
me become an inspiration
kids because I can say look if you see
something and you want to try it give it
a try
hey Webelos your scout leader is the new
Fortune fire Champion I'm bringing it
home should I have a group hug please
thank you you guys oh my God
the 1796 British light Cavalry saber
the 1796 English light Cavalry sword was
first used by British dragoons and
Napoleonic Wars
unlike the suddenly boat French Cavalry
Sabers of the era the English version
had a deep curve whose width increased
as it reached the tip although this
design weakened the Blade's thrusting
capabilities and made every slash
heavier and more brutal
designed to inflict maximum damage
during large melees on the battlefield
the saber had the ability to remove
heads and limbs with a single stroke
the light Cavalry sword is the weapon of
the traditional wooden Christmas
Nutcracker and can be seen at the iconic
soldier's side in the latest film
adaptation of the Tchaikovsky nutcracker
ballet the Nutcracker in the four realms
Lee Smith welcome to the kill test
keeping with this Christmas theme I'm
gonna take your weapons to deliver some
slashes and chops on this Christmas ham
you're up first you ready for this let's
do it
all right Jamie the first thing that I
noticed is the extreme weight
automatically I could feel the stress on
my hand it wants to fall forward now
let's talk about the blade this is a
chopper that gets work done in three
chops your weapon sir will kill thank
you
all right point where you're not here
and nice because it's your turn
I don't know let's see
all right Boyd you nailed the weight
this proves that a light sharp blade is
just as deadly as a heavier sword
overall sir your Nutcracker saber or
keto thanks
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test now to test the strength
of your Sabers I will be chopping into
this ice block
Jamie you're up first you ready I am
the biggest issue I have with your blade
is it's weight but for this test it's a
strong blade it held up so good job
thank you
all right Boyd you ready I don't know
all right so boy now your Blade's still
sharp it still has a perfect Edge didn't
take any damage that way but
we did pick up a bit of a warp towards
the tip I mean it's definitely an issue
it's not so far out that it wouldn't cut
everything else is still tight and
together good job yes sir
all right blade Smith now it's time to
find out there's any Edge left in your
weapon this is the sharpness test the
Christmas tree trim
to find out how sharp your edges are I
will trim this tree in the market family
Christmas Tree tradition Jamie you're up
first you ready for this trim away
foreign
side and it's still heavy but on every
stroke I'm able to trim this tree
overall sir
it'll cut thank you
all right boy it's your turn are you
ready to do some Christmas tree trimming
[Music]
all right Boyd so your Edge is sharp and
the weight that you have for this I
didn't have to reset for every cut that
I did I just go up cut up cut up and cut
overall sir
little cup thanks
Jamie had issues with weight I was good
with weight but my blade bent during the
strength test right now we're pretty
even
so basically it's down to a heavy blade
and a Bent Blade and I am just shaking
in my boots
all right gentlemen the judges and I
have had a quick conference and they've
made their final determination about
which of you was the forge and fire
champion and who has to leave the forge
he played Smith leaving the forges
Jamie
now unfortunately Jamie your blade did
not make the cut that's because it's
very heavy and unwieldy and for that
reason I have to ask you to please leave
the forge
I feel really disappointed but I'm not
surprised at all I know how heavy my
sword was I just wish I could have done
better
Boyd congratulations you are the force
and fire champion and that is the title
that comes with a check for ten thousand
dollars Merry Christmas my friend
anything to say to the world uh Merry
Christmas all right my friend come on
over and Shake our hand
[Music]
I'm really happy the way that the sword
turned out I was a little nervous when I
saw it take that bin but I couldn't ask
for a better performance out of it ten
thousand dollars is a great Christmas
gift to me yeah it's gonna be exciting
my son will be off the walls probably
for the next month and a half
General George Washington's lion-headed
cutto
one of only two swords worn by General
George Washington during the
Revolutionary War the lion headed Kato
was Washington's trusted sidearm during
early American engagements he was proud
that the weapon was made in America
having been custom forged by a
bladesmith in Philadelphia
well in battle the sword was designed
for Rapid cuts and brutal thrusts to
take down an opponent in the famous
painting Washington Crossing the
Delaware artist Emmanuel loitza places a
more refined weapon at the General's
left side which he did not acquire until
several years later in reality the sword
carried by Washington on that fateful
Crossing was likely his line-headed Kato
all right veterans welcome to the Keel
test
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your weapon will do I will take your
weapon deliver killing blows to this big
carcass I'm here up first ready
I'm ready
[Music]
all right Tyler your handle construction
just right your Edge is very sharp
overall sir this saber will kill perfect
all right Gene your turn sir you ready
let's do this Doug
[Music]
all right jeans this is a heavy sword
very forward heavy but when you have a
forward heavy blade that you're hitting
it meets resistance
a cylindrical almost circular handle
makes a Twist in my hand so probably
this is the reason why the chain came
off
but your blade is sharp it will heal
all right gentlemen December 25th 1776
George Washington leads the Continental
Army across a frozen Delaware River to
attack the Hessians at Trenton New
Jersey and he probably didn't chip his
way through the ice but that's not going
to keep us from our strength test the
ice block chop
Tyler you're up first are you ready uh
yeah yeah let's do it
all right so Tyler if your chain fell
off
but there's no damage on your Edge
your handles comfortable other than the
chain you nailed it good job
all right Gene do it
all right Gene your blades Edge
it's still there I'm still sure the
issue is of the rest of your chain fell
off and it's picked up a Bend I have
less issue with that and more issue with
this polished handle it's just hard to
hold on to but
it is strong
and it does have an edge so good job
all right veterans our sharpness test
today is the hessen charge
this is all about what your Edge will do
to these dummies calorie up first you
ready for this yep
all right Tyler the weight of your
weapon does prevent me from going very
fast but you have a very sharp edge all
the way through your webinar it will cut
thank you
all right Gene it's your turn sir you
ready let's do this Doug
to be able to maintain a good grip on
this more of the cuts I create are more
impact as opposed to a slash where it
cuts all the way through so you have
some Cuts here they're more Nicks deep
Nicks because you have a very sharp edge
and for this tester your weapon it will
cut awesome
it takes a lot of guts to get out there
and compete I'm glad I did it and to
come this far is pretty amazing I
definitely got the competition that I
was expecting from Gene but I think it's
going to come down to the wire between
the both of us at the end of this
Tyler Jean first of all I want to thank
you both for your service you're both
champions in my mind you've already won
your branch divisions but there can only
be one battle of the branches champion
and you'll walk out of here with a check
for fifty thousand dollars and that
champion is
Tyler congratulations you are the battle
of the branches forged and fire champion
Gene the blade didn't make the cut
please surrender your blade
the Marines out there and there's a lot
of great guys in the Marine Corps and so
for me to stand here and represent them
is pretty humbling
Tyler congratulations you overcame every
obstacle set in front of you you beat
out all the other Smiths and now you're
the battle of the branches forged and
fire Champion that's a title that comes
with a check for 50
000 and most importantly bragging rights
good job my brother please present your
blade to the judges
I'm super excited when this whole thing
started I had no idea I was all going to
turn out it feels good to have
represented the Army the fact that I
just won fifty thousand dollars is the
is starting to set in
I'm Sergeant Tyler Hackbarth and I'm the
new battle of the branches champion
the Irish ring hilted sword
dating back to the 12th century the
Irish ring-hilted sword was a classic
European weapon with a blade reaching
lengths of up to 40 inches the broad
double-edged weapon featured a
distinctive ring pommel that was key for
counterbalancing its weight allowing for
Swift and deadly Cuts commonly used by
the elite mercenaries known as Gallo
glass the well-balanced sword
complemented their Superior fighting
techniques that were revered throughout
Ireland in the Middle Ages although
Warriors such as the gallowglass no
longer exist the weapon symbolism is
still represented in popular culture
today and can be seen on the television
show Game of Thrones where one of the
most feared characters a mountain wields
his ring-hilted sword
all right blades bits this is the kill
test
you find out what kind of lethal damage
your Irish ring Hilton swords can do I
will take your weapon and deliver
killing blows on this feral bore carcass
Chase on Europe first you ready I am
let's do this
[Music]
all right Jason first up when I grab
onto it it feels good in the hands good
fit now swinging this is sweet you have
a you have a very sharp edge that cuts
easily into this wild boar carcass
it will kill good job Jason thank you
all right Sean you ready yes sir let's
do this
[Music]
come on
[Music]
all right Sean let's talk about your
weapon right here first up when I
grabbed onto the handle it's got a good
feel to that I like that you put some
grooves in there because it fits nicely
to where my hand locks into it and I get
a very secure fit
a little heavier but the weight helps
push and cut into this Wild bar carcass
and most of all it will kill thank you
sir good job Ben
welcome to the strength test the dreaded
ice chop
to test the strength and durability of
your swords as well as their overall
construction I'm going to be chopping
mercilessly into this unforgiving block
of ice
remember this test is all about what
that ice does to your ring hilted swords
and not what your swords do the ice
chasing her up first you ready yeah go
ahead good
foreign
first things first the warp I think that
it being off center made it rotate in my
hand but the balance on the sword as you
can see is beautiful it's comfortable to
wield and you saw it held up well done
thank you Sean you're up how you feeling
nervous but excited all right let's do
it
[Applause]
foreign
the weight on this is a little tip heavy
I would have liked a little bit more
counterbalance on it but that being said
it's still a lot of fun to swing your
Edge held up beautifully everything's
right and tight well done thanks sir
next up is the sharpness test and for
that I give you to Dave
okay gentlemen now to test the sharpness
of your blade I'll be cutting through
this sugar cane I'll use both edges of
your blade now unlike the strength test
this is all about what your blades do to
that Target you want to see those cuts
nice and clean not canes broken or
pushed out of the way tasting up first
you ready I am okay
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
your handle construction you can see how
square that is right there when that was
in my backhand cut
I actually got into those canes and then
it rolled your Tang is now kind of
kicking off to one side
so that probably happened as that blade
caught that last cane and yanked down
but uh it's definitely a sharp light
really nice
Sean you're up are you ready yes sir
okay
nice
okay
first up your handle construction I like
a lot it's not rotating in my hand
it's a heavier sword
but the cuts are clean it's definitely a
sharp blade I like that hold on thank
you
Jason Sean the judge's deliberation is
complete they've made their final
decision the next forged Empire Champion
is
[Music]
Sean congratulations you're the new
forged and fire Champion Jason
unfortunately your blade didn't make the
cut please surrender your blade
I would have liked it won
but uh I'm proud of what I've done I
mean throughout this whole series of
tests
I made a strong sharp blade and it
performed equally as well so I'm happy
with it
Sean congratulations you're the new
forged and fire champion and that's a
title that comes with a check for ten
thousand dollars how do you feel about
that doesn't suck no it does not Sean
please present your blade to the judges
this whole experience it's pushed me
physically it's pushed me mentally parts
of it have been pretty brutal thank you
guys and I wouldn't trade a minute of it
for anything I've Had the Time of My
Life
foreign